here are three tips for you when it
comes to working in a motion design
while listening to music tip number one
is to set the mood for high energy
brighter projects choose fast and upbeat
songs and for slower darker projects
choose slower more haunting songs tip
number two is maintain focus a good
playlist blocks out distractions and
helps you stay in the zone leading to
longer and more productive work periods
and tip number three is Inspire
creativity to keep your mind engaged and
inspired create a playlist with
different genres of music try creating
your own playlist and see how it
enhances your creative process